[Música]
cuántas veces en una entrevista de
trabajo te han preguntado si tienes
hijos
si eres varón probablemente nunca te lo
hayan preguntado pero si eres mujer y en
edad reproductiva quizás cada vez que
atiendas a alguna vacante
y también te habrán llegado a preguntar
quién te los cuida o si no van a afectar
tu desempeño laboral incluso yo mismo
llegué a preguntárselo a alguna chica en
una entrevista de trabajo
mi idea siempre fue ser mamá eso siempre
estuvo en mis planes pero nunca estuvo
en mis planes abandonar mi profesión
para hacerlo cuando ya estaba embarazada
las otras mamás me empezaban a preguntar
obviamente vas a dejar de trabajar los
primeros cinco años de vida de tu hijo
no lo vas a dejar tantas horas en la
guardería es mucho tiempo
cuando regrese a mi trabajo después de
mi período de incapacidad materna mi
jefe me preguntó si mis prioridades
ahora no habían cambiado y como no iban
a cambiar pero yo en ese momento le dije
que no porque las latas de leche están
carísimas quizás en ese momento no le
presté mucha atención a todos esos
comentarios pero después cuando comencé
a hacer mi trabajo de tesis doctoral me
dieron de entre un listado de temas a
escoger y vi uno que decía embarazo e
imagen
y dije bueno me haría de trabajo y me
estoy acostumbrando a esto de ser mamá
ya tenía como un año y medio
acostumbrándome entonces dije esto está
perfecto suena muy interesante
investigar acerca de esto
sin embargo cuando empecé a investigar
me empecé a dar cuenta de datos que me
sacaron bastante de la idea que yo traía
de la evolución que traíamos en los
estereotipos en la discriminación
laboral y fueron datos desalentadores
que hasta me daban ganas de dejar de
hacer la tesis la verdad si me hacía
sentir muy mal y cuáles fueron esos
datos de los que yo me di cuenta
me di cuenta que únicamente que
solamente 2 de cada 10 mujeres
quiere abandonar su profesión está
interesada en trabajar únicamente en
casa me di cuenta también que en américa
latina' el 36 por ciento de las mujeres
perdón las mujeres tienen un sueldo 36%
más bajo que los hombres alrededor del
año 2000 y no solamente su sueldo es más
bajo en profesiones de igual nivel sino
que además tienen menor acceso a
prestaciones es menos probable que las
atiendan en sus puestos laborales por el
solo hecho de ser mamás sin olvidar
mencionar que están expuestas al
hostigamiento sexual y hasta pruebas de
no gravidez a ver si no están
embarazadas para que puedan entrar en
las empresas me di cuenta también que
para el 2016 en méxico únicamente 2 de
cada 10 empleadores eran mujeres
únicamente ese porcentaje de mujeres
están emprendiendo están dándole trabajo
a los demás me di cuenta también por mi
investigación propia que 72% de las
madres se ha sentido discriminadas se ha
sentido menospreciada en su trabajo por
el solo hecho de ser madre y con esas
estadísticas por supuesto que
no me quedaban ganas de continuar dije
como les voy a decir cómo se van a
vestir las mamás qué mensaje de poder
van a enviar de liderazgo si hay una
brecha salarial de enorme
un día viendo en facebook una revista de
negocios me di cuenta de un artículo que
venía acerca de esa brecha salarial que
existe entre hombres y mujeres por los
mismos puestos de trabajo
pero yo lo que me pongo a ver es no nada
más lo que dice el artículo sino que
comentan las personas y esas personas
decían pues como no van a ganar menos
que los hombres y son cocineras si
fueran ingenieras hoy esta revista ya se
está volviendo fémina así
y saben quiénes serán las que más
atacaban a las mujeres las otras mujeres
las otras mujeres realizaban comentarios
desagradables
sobre nosotras mismas y yo dije bueno
pues si esto es cierto si la gente viera
mi investigación se daría cuenta que
existe esa brecha salarial y que no
solamente es una brecha salarial que son
muchas diferencias entre los géneros a
la hora de estar en el ámbito laboral y
que quiere decirnos esto que no ha
habido una redistribución del cuidado al
interior de las familias
quiere decir que sigue existiendo esa
lucha entre el trabajo y el hogar quiere
decir que seguimos viviendo en un modelo
obsoleto que empuja a las madres a salir
del ámbito laboral
o que empuja a los profesionistas a no
ser madres
y yo me pregunto en esta imagen porque
yo no puedo estar así tanto en el ámbito
profesional como si quiero estar a gusto
con mi hija en casa si se enferma porque
no me puedo dar un descanso para
quedarme con ella cuidarla hay otros
países como en europa en donde se
encuentran luchando para que se amplíen
los periodos por paternidad
por paternidad para el hombre en mexico
le decimos eso a las mujeres y dicen la
cuarentena es para la mujer es su
periodo de reposo después del parto
queremos darle permiso a los hombres
para que vayan a los festivales porque
ellos también quieren ir a ver a sus
hijos y ese flojo para que quieren
faltar nada más quiere pretextos
en tanto nosotros sigamos exigiendo
únicamente para la mujer esa brecha solo
se va remarcando se va haciendo más
grande mientras yo no exija lo mismo
para mujeres que para hombres únicamente
estoy reforzando y qué es lo que va a
pasar ahora no nada más van a decir las
empresas
no la contraté es porque no vaya a ser
que esté embarazada si no no la vais a
encontrar en contratar porque hay que
darle el período de incapacidad
ahora hay una ley que le tiene que dar
flexibilidad de horario pero si yo le
otorgo lo mismo a hombre que a mujer
entonces me da lo mismo a quien contrate
porque yo sé que si es hombre o es mujer
y tiene un hijo de todas maneras le voy
a tener que dar el mismo periodo de
incapacidad
pero cómo se logra todo esto es la gran
interrogante como un logro realizar esa
conciliación entre el trabajo y la
familia platicando con un empresario en
alguna de las entrevistas que hice para
mi tesis doctoral me decía que era una
utopía que la conciliación es un sueño
y yo como soy muy aferrada dije no es
que tiene que ser posible tiene que
haber una manera de lograrlo no tengo
por qué escoger entre un éxito u otro
sino que puedo compaginar ambas cosas
según la investigación esa conciliación
se puede lograr a través de la equidad
en un error o un primer movimiento del
feminismo fue pedir la igualdad en la
igualdad que queríamos ser iguales que
los hombres entonces accedemos a los
puestos de trabajo en las empresas y ya
venían de un modelo masculino donde pues
a lo mejor el hombre no se tiene que
salir temprano en la tarde o ya no
digamos temprano a su hora de salida no
tiene que salirse si a su hijo le da
fiebre
y entonces comenzamos a copiar esos
patrones masculinos a vestirnos más
masculinas a no tener hijos que puedo no
querer tener hijos excelente pero qué
pasa cuando si los quiero tener y lo
quiero compaginar con el ámbito laboral
escalan las mujeres en las
organizaciones y se topan con ese techo
invisible que no les permite subir a los
más altos puestos directivos porque
porque se considera que si no se queda
la jornada extendida pues no tiene
suficiente compromiso con la empresa o
va a comenzar con sus pretextos y sus
compromisos personales y ahí comenzó a
forjarse ese modelo de esas mujeres de
hierro que no tenían hijos que a lo
mejor ni siquiera estaban casadas
y qué pasaba con aquellas que si lo
querían estar
cuando nosotros pedimos equidad hablamos
de que debe haber igualdad de derechos y
obligaciones por el solo hecho de ser
humanos pero cuando hablamos de equidad
estamos hablando de que debemos evaluar
cuáles son las necesidades de cada uno a
veces decimos no pues es feminista hasta
que tiene que cargar un garrafón bueno a
lo mejor su necesidad es diferente que
la del hombre cuando llueva lo esas
necesidades y ninguno queda abajo del
otro ninguno tiene más poder entonces es
cuando existe esa equidad llévalo a sus
necesidades veo que es lo que le puede
ofrecer a cada uno
pero cómo vamos a lograr esa equidad si
llevamos tanto tiempo en la historia
haciendo lo mismo cuando nosotros se nos
genera una imagen acerca de las mujeres
de los hombres y la sostenemos a lo
largo del tiempo se vuelve verdad si a
nosotros nos enseñan eso desde pequeños
nosotros vamos a replicar esos mismos
patrones mi propuesta es que es posible
y es posible a través de la
implementación de nuevas políticas en
las empresas cuando las empresas
incluyen los horarios flexibles el ser
amigable con las familias los bancos de
horas los bancos de prestaciones cuando
se puede trabajar desde casa
entonces las empresas están ayudando a
ser inclusivos con mamás pero también
con papás con papás que quieren ser
incluidos en la crianza con papas que
quieren estar los primeros días de vida
con sus hijos que también se quieren
salir si su hijo se enferma y no nada
más salirse para no trabajar sino que
puedo ahora con las tecnologías de
información trabajar desde mi casa
nuevamente esas políticas tienen que ser
tanto para hombres como para mujeres
para que esa conciliación para que ser
amigables con la familia sea para ambos
géneros nuevas políticas públicas porque
si la mamá sale a trabajar y no a
guarderías suficientes guarderías
eficientes las guarderías gratuitas no
son para hombres y no son viudos un
hombre no puede acceder a una pensión si
no dependía económicamente de su esposa
entonces mientras yo no implemente los
mismos beneficios para ambos géneros
voy a seguir remarcando su estereotipo
voy a seguir diciendo las mujeres son
las que estos se tienen que salir
etcétera
como más puedo ayudar a programar esa
equidad a través de redes y mentoría
cuando yo tengo algo un modelo exitoso
que mostrar un modelo académico un
modelo en el sector laboral entonces
enseño a otras a que lo hagan a veces
subimos y decimos yo tenía mucho que
batalle en ellas como yo batalla
en lugar de comenzar a ayudarlas no les
voy a regalar nada pero tampoco voy a
hacer inevitable que puedan subir les
facilitó el camino a las que vienen
atrás porque esas que vienen después
pueden ser mis hijas
y también si soy hombre si soy hombre y
yo sé cómo manejar esos modelos entonces
ayudo a mis compañeras para que puedan
ir subiendo nos enseñamos unos a otros y
redes ahora redes cibernéticas a través
de las cuales con otras mamás con otras
profesionistas
yo puedo compartir qué es lo que me ha
funcionado qué es lo que se puede
realizar ideas que se están haciendo en
otros países con educación la educación
imprescindible y este tercer punto
la educación desde que somos niños
el otro día llega a mi hija y me dice
que quería un guardián espacial un buzz
lightyear
yo no le vi ningún problema
la niña lo tiene pero un día llegó de la
guardería y me dice
oye mamá
es cierto que yo no puedo jugar con mi
voz yo por qué
dicen mis compañeros que ese juguete es
nada más para niños
tres años
tres años tienen esos niños y ya alguien
les dijo
con que pueden o no jugar las niñas que
el azul es para los niños que los
carritos son para los niños ya alguien
su papá le dijo que no escogiera cierta
carrera porque es para hombre o es para
mujer
entonces si no estoy educando a desde
mis niños pues qué es lo que les estoy
enseñando que los hermanos le deben
calentar las tortillas a las hermanas
y es una educación para toda la sociedad
una reeducación para nosotros que ya
estamos grandecitos y nos va a costar
más trabajo para hombres punto
fundamental para alcanzar la
conciliación y la equidad pero también
para mujeres
porque si yo no puedo definir para mí
qué es el éxito si yo no me puedo
empoderar si yo no me conozco entonces
aunque los demás del otro género haga lo
necesario entonces yo no me voy a poder
empoderar no voy a poder surgir y el
último sería la emb el emprendedurismo
el emprendedurismo en general porque
espero todos los que están escuchando
esto si van a realizar un proyecto pues
ya desde las raíces que traiga esas
ganas de la inclusión ese empuje para
incluir a ambos para lograr esa
conciliación entre el trabajo y la
familia pero el emprendedurismo femenino
es fundamental es fundamental para ir
cambiando sus patrones en las
organizaciones
las mujeres implementan acciones de
responsabilidad social en mayor medida
enseñan a otras cómo hacerlo las llevan
a sus empresas
pero entonces porque dijimos al
principio que solamente 2 de cada 10
mujeres están siendo empleadores es la
doble jornada laboral el juicio social
de que me salgo de mi casa o no estoy
suficiente en el trabajo es la falta de
empoderamiento
el día de hoy yo vengo a invitarlos a
que busquen cada uno cómo romper ese
paradigma cómo lograr esa conciliación
entre el trabajo y la familia cómo
romper esa lucha y romperla desde casa
no diciendo yo soy ayudo a mi esposa
no nosotros hacemos equipo hacemos
equipo para lograrlo cuando yo veo a un
género abajo del otro y no solamente
hablando de la familia tradicional
porque puede ser el hombre y la mujer en
el ámbito laboral entonces es cuando yo
voy buscando cómo cambiar ese paradigma
por eso el día de hoy
yo vengo a dejarlos con esta frase de
ansuini
define el éxito en tus términos
consíguelo por tus propias reglas y
construye una vida de la que estés
orgulloso
[Aplausos]
[Música]